at the beginning of donald trump's
presidency we talked about this thing
called the emoluments clause of the
constitution which basically says that a
person who's holding office in the
united states cannot profit as a result
of holding that office they can't accept
presence or emoluments or anything else
of any kind whatsoever from anybody a
king prince or foreign state of any kind
now this was disturbing because Donald
Trump has so many different ways that he
could and has been profiting from the
presidency and very very early on in the
presidency a bunch of diplomats came to
Washington DC and they said hey we would
be inclined to stay at Donald Trump's
Washington DC hotel to try to ingratiate
ourselves with Trump we also had Trump's
new downtown DC hotel host events for
various embassies Azerbaijan and Kuwait
and others and they switched to Trump's
hotel from their original booking at the
Four Seasons but if no one was telling
them from the Trump administration or
State Department hey you should stay at
Trump's hotel it's kind of hard to prove
that there was actual wrongdoing we now
have the next level of this nonsense
Arturo
saru Khan is a former Mexican ambassador
to the United States and he recently
tweeted in Spanish that he was told by a
former American diplomat that the State
Department is emphasizing to world
leaders that they should stay at Donald
Trump's hotels when they come to the
United States for official visits he
tweeted this in Spanish and I'll kind of
give you the translation as we go here
and what he said was
kakastico c.x a US official tells me
that State Department protocol was
instructed to emphasize to other
governments that they use Hotel Trump
for official trips to DC now EU you
might see that in the tweet he actually
says EU and I translate it as American
it that doesn't mean European Union the
word in Spanish is a Stallone II then
say which means which means American and
I'm seeing people comment and say that
he's talking about the European Union
he's not he's talking about the United
States and caki stock recei is a system
of government run by the worst least
qualified people
and it's pretty clear that that's
exactly what we have going on if this is
true this isn't a swamp this is a gilded
swamp being run by Donald Trump but most
importantly it's a major ethics
violation is it even worth talking about
there is no chance that this is going to
be seriously looked at but this hotel
stuff is truly blurring the lines
between Trump the president and Trump
the real estate tycoon for lack of a
better term and it's an outright
violation of the Constitution if the
State Department is actually incur
encouraging foreign diplomats to stay at
Donald Trump's hotel I am NOT a defender
of major hotel chains like Marriott and
Hilton but if I were them I'd be looking
at legal action here because this is a
government getting in the way of your
business by recommending Trump hotels
when foreign diplomats and world leaders
come to visit the United States on
official visits I thought Republicans
were against government getting in the
way of business guess if it's the
president businesses it's a whole
different story